new notebook
LP
example
one
I would say this is a it would be a good idea for you to follow along
by the way to actually type along.
example one
Okay. So first we're not going to use numpy just
yet. We're going to use matplotlib.
Import if you're using colab this
library is already pre installed.
So I'm going to go Matt.
plot lip
Dot pipelot
as
PLT
quick question how many of you are familiar with this Library?
And I've used it if you know it and used it before typing y.
Otherwise type it in the chat.
Okay, fine. Okay. See some questions here. No one
asks.
Do you don't you want to minimize the objective
function don't you want to minimize the cost?
No, you're right in this example. We want to maximize the profit.
Okay.
If we sell these containers we will
earn.
A sense on the dollar so that that's what we that's
what we want to know.
There's the cost associated with manufacturing them. And then there is
the revenue we get from selling them. What is
how much you will profit?
Okay, of course we can then turn that we can turn this problem around
and trying to minimize the objective
function if it had to with the cost associated with it, but this is
about maximizing profit.
Okay.
Okay, everybody knows math problem. I don't need to say much about that. But
let me go ahead and you know plot this
problem.
So the first thing I'm going to do is generate a
list.
of numbers
there is
A method within actually, I made a mistake. We
do need that part import.
but it's it's just
to produce some to produce some numbers.
Let me import no pi.
So X is going to be equal to NP Dot
and we're going to produce a linear space.
A line a set of linear set of values.
from 0
that's the starting number.
Two, let's make it 100 and we want
two thousand.
Numbers in this range. So this is a set of real numbers.
0.1 0.2.
all the way to 1,000
because the way we can produce a line.
on Matlab is to have
a sequence of points a sequence of
XY points. So we need to trace.
Along the X and Y axis.
so we have X
goes from 0 to 100.
And I'm going to express.
the constraints
as functions of Y
So let me give you the code.
So here we are plotting.
the constraints
as equated obviously not equalities.
How do we get this? How did we get this function? Well if I
come down
here
It's this one.
What we've done?
Is we have moved 200?
To the right side of the equation so we get 4,000. Obviously. I'm
not including the million. I I don't want a graph
that is that large I will label in the
graph. I will label in the X and Y axis but I'm dropping the
times the scientific notation from here, but
it is 100 y equals 4,000 minus
200 x so 4,000
- 200 times x
and the to get rid of The 100.
I'm going to divide both sides of the equation.
So if we divide both sides of the equation, let me actually make this
swine y.
sub 1 and y sub 2
Okay, make it less this confusing.
So to get rid of the 100s.
I'm going to divide both sides of the equation by 100 divide
this side of the equation with 100 you get y1,
you get and divide.
This sort of the equation.
You get Y2.
Okay, so I'm really expressing.
These constraints as functions of Y.
I'm doing something here.
I'm moving 100 to the right side of the equation. So we get 3,000 minus
100. So 3,000 minus 100 and
then of course to get rid of the 100. I'm going to divide both Saturday
equation, okay.
and then
I need to set the limits of my
plot.
Math plot, it would automatically set the
limits of on the X and Y axis, but I want to
maybe leave some room.
for visualization
then I'm going to plot.
both of these
equations. I'm going to plug both of these.
constraints
this is going to be y sub 1 this will be y sub 2.
Okay.
Going to run this.
So just to make it especially clear. This is
the first
constraint
so our solution area is limited to
You know this triangular region.
but then when we involve the second
constraint
now well now we're confined to this region.
And you can see we have an intersection in here.
We would have we have just found this we found this by.
Finding the roots in our constraints and
we find we found out that the point.
On the feasible region is 10 and 20.
So we can take this and we can plot to indicate it.
So whatever our objective function is going to be maximized to it must.
Not leave this area.
Okay, so let me show you what I mean.
and
Let me relabel this one. So for
the first constraint
we have X must be greater than or equal to 0 so X.
Must be greater than or equal to.
and then y must be greater than or equal to.
so plot
the
constraints
This is an equations and this is this was supposed
to be Express.
Express the constraints
as functions
of Y
All right.
Now the point the point that indicates the
physical region.
We use the plot method.
The point on the x-axis the point on the y-axis.
And then here we could choose the marker and the size of
the marker and give it a color.
so plot
the point
indicating
a feasible
region
There we go.
so objective function
must
go through this point.
Okay, so we're getting closer to the solution.
and then
let me show you how I can fill in the region.
I can fill in the regions.
So I'm going to there's a method called.
the
field between method
so we have y sub 1
y sub 2
and then we want to plot the region.
that where
the points in our first
constraint or less than the second constraint again.
This is what this is what it looks like.
and it did not work because
because
Yeah, because we have okay, this was something else. This was
supposed to be the masking area.
So before we mask.
Let me actually plot the gray areas. So this will be through between
so shade
the regions
under the constraints
So first, we'll do the first constraints. That's
why I said one.
Which will give us that.
And then I'll pay for the second constraint. So why sub
Okay, and this other plot, let me disable this
for the second for a second.
We want to get rid of these regions.
So we should only see Gray.
In the feasible region, and so what I'm going to do is I'm going to mask.
These areas.
So I'm going to use the fill between method again, but I'm gonna
set the color to white and the alpha to one.
now I will do this for both of the